hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I want to talk about
one of my favorite tools that I use for
my my business and it's called
rapportive and what it is is a gmail
plug-in that tells you more about the
people who are in contact with you so
there's a gmail version is also an
Outlook version and let me just go
search for rapportive so this is my page
of my favorite tools that I use I
showcase on my blog and rapportive is
one of them that I use so rapportive is
for Gmail you can use Omni for Outlook
which I used to use I think sapne has
come up with a version for Gmail as well
but I'm kind of stuck on rapportive I'm
hooked so let me tell you a little bit
more about what rapportive does click on
the link loaded up here and what it does
is if you guys are used to Gmail you'll
see your normal Gmail here on the side
and then this will usually be a bunch of
odds so what it does is replace the odds
with information about the person who is
in contact with you so I'll quickly show
you what it looks like on my Gmail and
hopefully I don't give away too much
personal information here so I'll click
on Maria's first so Maria is somebody
who works for me she's my marketing
manager and what you do is you see you
know my email from Maria here on the
side it'll show me information about
Maria so instead of seeing ads it'll
show me
Maria's picture email address where she
is her position her Twitter account and
recent tweets so if you want to connect
with them you can read a little bit what
what they're tweeting the belt you can
write back or just learn a little bit
about them you can see them
if you're on Facebook together you can
see if you're on LinkedIn together etc
so we are friends we're on LinkedIn you
can hover over and you can see some of
her facebook comments and LinkedIn as
well we're connected and Twitter it'll
show within your stream here so it's
pretty cool that it shows you detailed
information about them instead of having
to go search for them yourself online to
these various accounts and it's way
better than just seeing ads so let me go
back so that's Maria let me load up
Louisa Louisa a colleague of mine you
his own business last-minute training so
here shows again his picture it pulls
the picture in from various sources this
is pulling it in from LinkedIn and we
can see his picture here too and we can
help her oversee some information but
here's his picture
again Toronto his company his Twitter
account which I'm not following so I
will have to follow and just like that
I'm not following Louie on Twitter we
are friends and we're LinkedIn connected
as well so that's great and I'm one
click away from being able to go to his
Facebook page or LinkedIn page if I want
more information what he's doing
so again way better than seeing ads and
gives me a little bit information on who
this person is now I know Louie while
which is great it's super useful as well
when you're being contacted by people
who you may not know as well so
potential customers prospects media if
you show the information on them it
gives you a little bit better
understanding of who they are and maybe
some details about their lives which
might help you and close in a deal
something we'll look at one more just so
you guys get the sense
let's click down here so this is a out
of office reply so even though you know
there's no actual email here besides out
of office it'll still look up this
information so here's Frances Fernandez
you know president of this company
exclaimed solutions it'll show his
Twitter I'm not following so again I can
just follow if I want it'll show recent
tweets so you know stay away for booze
for forty five days when I quit smoking
that was a big one for me so he's he's
proudly quick smoke smoking there's
something didn't know about him so now I
have information that kind of gives me
greater insight into Francis's life and
this is a public tweet so hopefully
there's no issues there and we're not
connected so I can connect if I want he
has a Flickr account and just basically
you know it's great a just to see
pictures of people see what they look
like I find when everything's in an
online world and you know we're getting
so much email I'd like to be able to see
what people look like and then being
able to get deeper into some of their
information be able to one-click follow
people respond if I want I can reply
directly through here I can retweet if I
want up and click right
to that tweet and it's free so you know
best word for entrepreneurs it's a free
tool and it replaces all the eyes so
there's really no lose for installing
rapportive in on on your Gmail again
here's the link if you go back to my
page of tools I'll link to it and also
is Omni which is the Outlook version
which I really enjoyed using when I was
on about look as well so hopefully that
gives you a useful tool to test out and
put into your business if you guys liked
the video please give it a thumbs up I
always appreciate it and love seeing the
thumbs up coming in on the videos and if
you have any thoughts or questions
please leave a comment under the video
I'll do my best to answer them and maybe
make a video just for you
so thank you and stay tuned for next
episode
you